yes
you have to have it
now
or longer, hold on
thank you very much
[Music]
with that
well
here it
has to be like this
here
[Applause]
oh
and of course
[Music]
oh
never saying that
i
[Music]
more
neuer neuer
[Music]
andrés granier
here
you can escape
in Spanish to the box
to listen to the bottle and
I got separated
but mark
this iron bar
of salsa
well
na na na let's
see
and I'm going to have them they want me they tell me
here
to  more
characters
well
walking stuff
step i want
tangier west thanks
formation
as
it is believed
[Music]
it is not crisis in top boxes well
no
i
[Music]
onewest
what it means
a month and thursday
a
is a measure
why
such that
whitacre
now
I
raise back afammer  is that alonso stallion
until
this attack
in nerve
harvard 10 hours
and sing
prophecy come to have that I don't know
why not bewkes
the discards
[Music]
at work
I like it in art I
explained
it won't grow
Busquets sell cards
nice
later
through carbon expansion is the
tenaris balance of g
and
today
[Music]
and sat
from that to
come
has this
thanks
[Music]
yes
from here
[Music]
expert
but  the cause
[Music]
sardi
carnes land
[Music]
is scarce
ah it
was part of athens
[Music]
or shanghai
it goes
[Music]
here
as
[Music]
here
more than now
skinny zidane
for the south
like maya  well, you can also move
[Music]
or
av
i
[Music]
is also capable
and of
course
less
if they want me to speak
[Music]
and
in this month
[Music]
we would stay
with what there is
already they will be  days
every
time sometimes
why sometimes
yes
but it is that in this
the will is
yes
at this point my country
and I want
[Music]
more theme
and why
wow that requires shelter
plus being an
engadget well far behind
not even the bar
animal
[Music]
just
another 1000
yes
[Music]
hi bred
you had
try
6 as
much  pica
soft
[Music]
gasol
the terminator
[Music]
there is no need to wish
mira wars
to create someone normal
[Music]
to the
ambient chapel substrate
although today we will get nothing
fractions force
ah
yes
for example with flipping
in euros
and
[  Music]
[Music]
ah
in the sprint
before
[Music]
[Applause]
ok
wake up
[Music]
sad
writes arq
[Music]
many years
every month they do
and still night
[Music]
no
I think yes
to nava  decided normal
efe
dr why
here
[Music]
enough laughter
the system
badly
maybe
[Music]
hamaikabat snake
and very well
craving
water flooded with chain
then
today
[Music]
ah
to 1
[Music]
me
the god
[Music]
there is now
at random
and well
[Music]
now
here
[Music]
I am another way times
because of this bad
fire wall
then back
ah
[Music]
I hope
arrives
[Music]
they are the crown
that's how it
was until it took
me then  you would be better
[Music]
well
[Music] it
was
on youtube
tag
that
[Music]
ah it
was natalia
how
close a tangle
here is going to be
[Music]
and direct
p fashionable
mine
heidegger how are
which
[Music]
the same
next
in castellón
i
what
's today in
the stands
lose
[Music]
love yourself
hurt
the idea is that another huesca street
has been removed
[Music]
I have web
se  believe
[Music]
m
I have